I'd rather just be easy about it and
also there's other things about the
house I didn't like we've been house
hunting and it's hard yeah and we saw
one the other day that was close
what's funny how would you describe your
style I'm similar doesn't look like a
Japanese botanical home slash [ __ ]
Blade Runner Moscow like she doesn't
want a future it's like if it doesn't
look like it belongs in both the future
in the past yeah so hard to find man you
get a time machine bro oh well I swear
and it's like I think that I have his
taste down and I've come really close
that last one was close but it's just
not it yeah at this point I should be
your realtor I should be a realtor for
difficult people with big imaginations I
also don't understand why you wouldn't
just like design your own home okay cuz
because I know that okay this is what
Ellen DeGeneres does okay this is what I
heard but she likes to buy land and just
design a home from scratch okay yeah
she's a multi multi-millionaire she can
do that me I got one shot I'd never
designed [ __ ] before I think you'd be
amazing I know but I haven't done it yet
so I believe that if one day I have that
kind of money if I get lucky or whatever
then I could [ __ ] up on one house and go
I know I did it wrong what I did wrong
I'll give that to Steve yeah and then
you know I'll you know but I don't want
to [ __ ] up on the first one mmm because
I also my imagination going to go wild I
don't know what I what I can and cannot
do
your fallouts pretty orderly though yeah
your home's yeah because I want they
need to be functional yeah but they also
like well what was that but be
functional his homes that he makes on
fallout are all like there they all
should be in like architectural that
exactly they're really cool he's
actually he's got an eye for interior
design like much better than me
and he just has a cool
he has cool taste he really does I will
give you that but that's what I want
if I'm gonna smell that cut spend that
kind of money I'm gonna get a good one
I don't care where it is good one you
keep saying that it has to be a home
that you're gonna die in III III say
this okay we [ __ ] we saw three that I
would have got but though three that we
got there were problems with it the John
Legend House with the John Legend's at
house old house it looks great it's
amazing I would have got that but was
too it was a lot also we weren't quite
ready we weren't ready yet the second
house was in Silver Lake it was a
Japanese house it looked too much you
didn't like it I just couldn't I felt
like every time if I were to come home
to it it would feel like coming home to
like a creepy Museum like it was so
specific to the previous owners taste
that I felt like their soul rested in
the walls because there was so much it
it it was like everything the Japanese
sitz bath to the interior like there was
a koi pond and like a little like mini
park in the middle of the [ __ ] in the
middle in the middle of the living room
actual Park in yeah bench and like grass
and a koi pond in the middle in the
middle of the living room old Asian
people doing Tai Chi yeah there yeah it
was okay to get to it you take an
elevator yeah there's an LD that sounds
cool it looks so good and you know what
the thing is I imagine the elevator you
you you you you go up and you see a wall
just a blank wall but what I would do is
put images on that wall so when people
go to my house they'll see like you know
I mean like a handicapped kid in a
wheelchair and then it goes up and then
three black guys with their heart on
dicks so I got a story when you go up
the elevator so when people out of my
house right when people come up to the
final floor they know that's Bobby Lee's
house yeah yeah it took a museum Wray
Wray Wray Wray what I found out was I
think we found out that these two old
people designed the house in the 50s but
they died there I mean you could feel
that in the walls and I I'm for me it's
like I don't need no white [ __ ] got
old white ghosts just hanging out
okay so when you were if you would ever
buy a house Bryce or Gilbert don't you
think it's really important like when
you walk in no matter how beautiful it
is like how it makes you feel like if it
feels like oh there's like do you guys
have any water spirit like the back of
your neck hair like your hair stands up
and you're like whoa like this is a cool
place but it gives me like the
heebie-jeebies kind of well yeah
especially after hereditary it's like I
don't need like no need ghosts and
demons yeah I I'm afraid of I'm a friend
maybe it's race racist I'm a for some
reason if black people died in a house I
wouldn't be scared yeah me neither
why is that because I feel like Asians
died in the house I wouldn't be scared I
would be scared with Asians oh yeah yeah
Tokyo i watch enough right you just see
it like a wig up like a middle night you
see like a black wig somewhere and
you're like a year out there's no any
girl any girl black people would be real
nice Mexicans would be real nice
Filipino girls we appear to be sixty of
them
the Mexicans it's a party if you see yes
yes to every night
yeah man you'd be like oh my god people
in there oh you're right like always
having a fiesta they're good people what
was that last movie with I'm not sha Wan
with the grandparents the white
grandparents that one that's what I
think of a house of yeah yeah yeah
[Music]